hey I'm here for the PTA meeting am i
the teacher the parent no one knows
hi my name is first helping you do not
know now you know your life is different
now it's me what it's March it's March
its March and it's March this is how I
know I don't check my calendar on my
computer because I just tried to open my
calendar and it says what's new in
calendar continue you can configure
challenger features and preferences
alright it is March 1st it means it's
time to talk about the things that I
enjoyed throughout the month of February
aka my February favorites let's just do
it first yeah can't see ya see ya see ya
this is a black liquid eyeliner it's by
Nick's or NYX and it's called epic ink
liner and this stuff is amazing
I bought this ID randomly when I was
trying to avoid like actual
responsibilities by shopping for makeup
in a local convenience store and wearing
it on my eyes today wow wow I'm so bad
at describing makeup but here's what
I'll say about this it's really good
a lot of liquid liners for me or a
little too dry or that I can't I have a
hard time drawing with the felt tip that
they have Wow Dora checks out it works
very shaky hands most of the time but I
like to think of them it's just like
happy hangover hands this allows me to
draw very precise lines very easily and
it's a drugstore price I don't know how
much this pose exactly but I want to say
it's definitely under like $7 don't
quote me on it but it's likely maybe
possibly probably under seven dollars
but not definitely next yeah say yeah
yeah say yeah yeah say yeah these are
fragrance oils I wanted to call them
perfumes or scents but I am reading the
packaging now and they are fragrance
oils okay they're from a brand called
khumba made Kumba k uu mba so one day i
was smelling terribly good luck figuring
out what day that was and i was not near
my house and I was at Whole Foods buying
some food to eat for lunch anyway and I
walked past a like organic make up in
like tree bark tampon
aisle and I saw this display for khumba
made fragrance oil although I started
smelling them and then this woman came
up next to me on my shoulder like a pear
soccer-mom and was just like those are
great since it was weird because she was
in that like weird intimate kiss range
you know like as human beings we have
like these distance measures maybe it's
just me but like if someone's this close
to me regardless of like knowing them I
still think my brain like what should my
suppose I should probably kiss them
right now right like they're right here
but I didn't so that was enough for me
to fully buy into the product I got a
thing called black coconut and amber and
sandalwood and I got to say these are
really great they don't last a long time
I will say that you have to kind of keep
them with you and reapply but they're in
a 1 8 ounce bottle so you can travel
with them everywhere next yeah yeah say
yeah say yeah I say isn't a cure for
your hair for the planet dry shampoo
this is also a purchase from Whole Foods
it's a dry shampoo and it's awesome this
was purchased out of necessity more than
actually you know knowing anything about
how awesome this product is its color
safe vegan sulfate free paraben free and
cruelty free and it's one of the best
dry shampoos I've ever used in my hair I
was just coming from a girl that like
never showers I think my gauge of dry
shampoos is pretty good this is a powder
form rub into your hairline and it just
absorbs all the oils and this smells
really good it smells like you took a
shower neck yeah say yeah say yeah yeah
say it okay this product is great but it
also represents this whole like the line
of makeup products that I'm really
excited to talk about it's a line called
Bronx VR o and X colors my makeup artist
that I use all the time Val Mohawk
makeup on Instagram go follow her check
her out she's amazing if you've watched
any of my podcast episodes on full
screen she does all of my hair and
makeup for that she got in touch with
this company and they sent us a bunch of
product I get them a little weary when
my company send products oh my god that
must mean that those products aren't
doing very well they're sending me free
products but it send me a ton of stuff
and it's all really great but there are
two major products
from them that I love and this first one
is their skinny mascara I know that
might sound stupid but it is exactly
what it sounds like the one it's the
tiniest mascara wand ever is it even
there is this even real
I'll show me this ensures that you're
going to fall in love with their mascara
and then pull this out I was like mmhmm
mm-hmm
and then I came home and I used it and
holy [ __ ] I don't understand it and I
also don't understand it so my favorite
mascara is Too Faced better than sex I
think a lot of people also have that as
their favorite mascara this might be
better than that
it is so this is good okay going to
sound real gross you guys but this
mascara is no wet so precise it gets in
there so many sexual overtones
undertones and FS kara is so precise you
can get into the root of your lashes and
trust me it's very difficult to describe
this you should just get it and try it
for yourself
I think this brand is now being sold at
Ulta from what I hear you can also go
online I believe and check them out next
yeah do you see yeah say yeah this is
another wrong colors product this is
their contouring palette you can see
mine extraordinarily gross because I use
it constantly the highlights that
consorts instep blush for me this
contour color is the best like contour
color slash bronzer I've ever used I'm
using the blush write down using the
contour and I'm using the highlighters
on my face right now on the back they
give you a little demo and look how
happy the demo girl is she's like me
just extraordinarily happy about their
products it has everything all on a kind
of very convenience like relatively
small package that you can travel with
big fan Thank You Bronx colors yes can
say yeah yeah yeah oh yeah this is a
makeup brush from ELF LCLs
is makeup brand if you don't know that
is notoriously extraordinarily cheap but
their products aren't the worst and
they've started making these brushes
that are a little bit more expensive
than
the rest of the line but still insanely
inexpensive compared to other makeup
brands on their website it looks like
they're called beautifully precise I
thought they were called like hologram I
was at brush at Target I think it was
like I've been eight nine dollar
something like that which is way cheaper
than like a Sephora brush or a Mac brush
and it's awesome a better quality than
normal elf brushes where you know you're
going to brush your face and then you
should lint roll it because all of the
bristles have fallen out are your face
neck self is next these yes they can say
to use our workout pants by pop flex
active which is Cassie ho aka Blogilates
50 fly she sent me both of these pairs
of leggings in the last a couple months
and they are so awesome it cannot say
enough good things about them I run as
my primary source of fitness but I also
wear leggings as a primary source of
just normal everyday clothing these
really kind of bridge the gap these are
the newest ones that she sent me they're
like this reddish maroon color is this
mesh cutout on the side which lets your
legs breathe real cool leg and they got
zippers on the bottom these are black
version basically have the same thing
but here is the best thing about these
leggings and I cannot believe it's
taking me so long to find leggings with
this accessory it looks like normal
leggings right there's a pocket on the
side you can so perfectly place your
cell phone it's amazing this thing alone
she could put my stains all over the
rest of the leggings and I still be like
yes these are perfect weekend so what
happens they get too excited about
pocket on a legging next yeah can you
see yeah yeah this is a denim jacket
that I bought off of amazon.com because
I forget that you can buy things like
clothing on Amazon and a lot of people
do this is the brand it goes se7en on
the tag but I'm pretty sure the brand is
she in SA
see I n on Amazon this was $30 it's a
little bit longer it from like next to
waist and the sleeves are a little bit
like more crop so it's kind of made in
very weird proportions but I like it
and people have complimented me on it
which makes me like it more when people
think that I make good choices in my
life yeah yeah yeah say it my favorite
brand of all time poopourri has extended
their brand from toilets to shoes shoe
Paree guys this blew my mind it's the
shoe odor eliminator if you know me at
all you know that I am a big ol fan of
poo pourri bluebury is the spray you
spray in your toilet before you take a
[ __ ] and magically it makes it smell
like you've never taken a [ __ ] at all
it's like that mind eraser tool on men
in black but for people's noses and your
ass and now they've made a spray that
you can spray on your shoes that
eliminate shoe odor and it's great and I
don't know what to say about it but it's
great they're also a company that's just
obsessed with rhymes and puns it's so
stupid but they lean into how stupid
they're being and it makes me love them
even more stump
shoe odors and most of the products come
in travel-size bottles this is 2 ounces
wherever you are on the road no matter
what happens to your gastrointestinal
system or if you didn't realize that the
shoes that smell normal in your home
smell awful on the road you're taken
care of
don't change your lifestyle have it's
just match the bad things you've done to
your intestine and your shoes ok there
you go there my favorite favorite let me
know what you guys enjoyed this month
and if any of these things are
interesting to you leave a comment down
below and give this video a thumbs up if
you like favorites videos because I like
favorites videos so why not show that
you like them and click this button and
subscribe to this YouTube channel cuz
I'm here every Monday Wednesday and
Friday giving you content that you can
ignore but you also can't ignore it but
don't please
I don't know I've recently learned I
have a tiny widow's peak which leads me
to believe that I'm going to marry a
very tiny man we're going to live on the
top of the mountain and he's gonna die
before me
tiny widows